Wow that tree is huge it sure is
chaplain that's all you're gonna say all
right we can't all be winners hi this is
doug walker wishing you all a very Merry
Christmas I do this every year I just
talk about you know what a great time of
year this is and what a great seasons a
season of giving it's a season of love
and this year I really wanted to focus
on you guys and what you've been giving
and the love that you've been sharing
because at the end of our nostalgia
critic videos who's probably seen we do
charity shoutouts how we find a
different charity every week we try to
make sure that they're good charities
like they have good ratings and charity
watch and such and we just give a shout
out to them you know just to say if you
have a little pocket change or even now
if you want to give a lot to something
that you really care about you know
please do and then we started a new show
called out what you can do because
people have told me before all I like
this charity but I don't I don't have
money you know at times are tough you
know it is fair enough
so we started this new show where we
show what people can do to volunteer
their time and naturally allow them
around Chicago and some have gotten
volunteers you know and but it's in
Chicago I mean this has a wide wide
stretch so it's something where people
say like oh I want to go and volunteer
at a place like that so they'll go look
it up and one of the nice things is you
know I mean not every charity is gonna
get like tons and tons of money I mean I
know how this works but the nice thing
is that you know not only do some of
them get a fair amount but just sharing
it
sharing the info which allow you guys do
is very helpful because there's one that
told me that like they got a really big
donor from this person and I think they
were a camera where they were but they
were like now why are you is it's very
kind but why are you giving like this
amount instead they said that he saw on
Channel awesome and it's one of those
things where because people share it
because even if you don't have that
money or you're not close to the place
to volunteer or anything you're like let
me share this and maybe somebody want to
give a little bit more I mean even it's
just in most the time it's like just
what people can it's a little pocket
change here and there you know it even
that goes a long way but sometimes you
can find that person who you know it
either really connects with
or they're just like no I really want to
give a lot to this because this is
something that's very very special so I
just want to say you know keep even if
you don't have the money to give even if
you're not able to volunteer even if you
can't find a place near you where you
can volunteer you don't have the time or
something like that just share and this
is very much the season of sharing and
it's something where I say this in like
all the videos around Christmastime I
say christmas is a time of giving and
love and sharing and it should go beyond
this time it should last all throughout
the year and we don't all do that I
don't do that how do you know that like
anyone you know I get stuff in my life
around like I just wanna stay in and
watch a movie or something like that
when I could be doing you know something
else but it's something where if you
keep that idea just throughout the year
if you just keep sharing the good that
people do you know we like to share so
much stuff that happens online if we
just keep sharing charities and just
good I love what they do on Facebook
where you can give like on your birthday
you can like give something to a charity
like that's a great idea
you know it's stuff like that it's just
so helpful and so good and it's all
throughout the year it just keeps going
it keeps continuing and something that a
lot of people were asking me this year
after the Nutcracker video I did you
know and they found I didn't say the
f-word I'm nostalgia critic for for a
whole year and some people were
wondering why I mean they're like that's
really cool but but why did you do it
and my mom really hated that word she
liked what I did but she always says do
you have to use the f-word so many times
and after she passed it was something
where I was kind of saying to myself you
know I I know I don't you know I I know
people don't just watch me for that so
it was something where I always kind of
send the back of my head I want to say
it a little less I want to not like rely
on it like you know if I'm really good
at this I can use a joke without having
to rely on that word and then at some
point like I made a conscious effort I
said okay from this point on I want to
do at least a year not saying it at all
and I have already heard a lot of people
are going back to the videos like no he
must have said it here he must have say
hear it and I didn't it actually started
not this last October but the previous
October it started there so technically
it's over a year but but even before
and I was trying to sort of back off on
it and again I'm not I'm all for freedom
of speech I'm gonna I'm gonna still say
it but but I want to prove both to
myself and kind of to her I didn't need
to rely on it so it's something that the
reason I'm telling you this is because
just sometimes these little things can
they can have an effect I mean even if
it's not right away that simple kindness
you know can really go a long way I mean
we're in very extreme times right now
and sometimes just being quiet gentle
kind middle-of-the-road just
appreciating what you're getting and
appreciating more what you're giving and
giving and getting back and forth and so
on so forth I mean just appreciating
what people do for one another I think
you'll really go a long way and to me
that's Christmas that's keeping
Christmas alive the whole year and I
just want to say to you guys thank you
so much thank you for giving to these
charities thank you for volunteering and
may of them fate thank you for sharing
it just thank you for being like hey
this is a cool charity check it out and
sharing with a friend or something in it
may lead to nothing you never know if it
might lead to a really big donor it
might lead to a lot of donors you never
know with online you know if something
might really catch on or maybe you'll go
nowhere but it's it's always worth the
shot even if not much comes from it it's
more than what they had I mean we never
charge for these charities or anything
like that I mean that that'd be pretty
to she to do and and just a heads up the
reason we couldn't get November is
because we had one that then like the
hand event that came up and they had to
change it to a different month so that
that is coming in that December we were
moving just just go and get around to it
but next year they're gonna start up
again that the what you can do videos
are gonna start up right again and again
guys just it's it's the giving it's the
sharing and I just want to say thank you
so much again for giving and sharing I
mean I really do have the kindest fans
that will go out there and just say like
hey here's a cool organization check it
out they do good work and sometimes the
volunteers sometimes they'll give pocket
change sometimes they'll give a lot of
money so whatever you're doing whether
it's sharing whether it's giving just
thank you so much thank you for being
who you are and I hope you guys just
have a fan
Hasek holiday this really is my favorite
day of the year I love Christmas so much
it's just so much good around it and I
have so much good around me with my fans
and my friends and my family and just
thank you so much again and chaplain you
want to end this with a creepy head turn
very weird way to end this
you